you
created it's called the Heller arena get
ready for the Heller arena we are
waiting for 26 players mm-hmm and I will
not be going berserk unless necessary
towards the end and I need to try and
get some crazy win 14 players it's
filling up fast one a minute chess all
right
we are officially starting efore best
buy test there's a little timer can I go
for a quick kill quick kill just for fun
why not why not it's bullet
it is bullet let's go here attacking
that night I don't like how I'm playing
this nobody what do you expect what do
you expect exactly I could've taken that
fish up watch out for h2o alright umm
well that's cause the Queen some
problems maybe take care
I have h2 guarded take there definitely
take their Queens right now that I'm up
material attacking the knight that's
another piece I have d8 controlled by my
bishop if he's attacked I'll drop back
they resigned back to tournament
returned to tournament - somebody else
has to pair it up again just like that
man they're just too much fun that's the
problem
that's the big problem these are too
much fun why do you keep laughing thanks
can't move like pawns our pawns can't
move like Knights
tongue-tied again that's the usual case
b5 Bishop b7 complete your development
nothing fancy here get your pieces out
normally you have to worry about f-4e
for stuff let's get on this diagonal
before they do or at least get on it
immediately after they do
I'd really like a light square bishop
exchange let's top be 5 nonsense
I want to secure my night position is
what I really want to say we should be 7
connect Knights Castle look whoa look at
I could take here but I'll just do this
attacking the knight and still on I'm on
em to move the knight I take F to their
own castled I could take here too are
they gonna do they're spending a ton of
time less than 10 8 here pretty much no
matter what let's just go here no matter
what
then I'm anytime time burners back to
tournament four four four four I'm in a
tie for first time for first why did I
start out with Knight f3 that's uh need
a scotch scotch gambit who really no
that's not right I got their night let's
play here target f7 Castle this is an
open e file get a rook they're very fast
Queen check I'll drop the ship back I
don't want to trade Queens Queen here's
inconveniencing the bishop a different
case if the bishop was already developed
that's very weakening they're definitely
not castling now I could do that pretty
much no matter what unless Bishop b4
they're spending a lot of time here big
trouble it's big trouble
Knight takes pawn Knight takes here less
than 20 develop clean side castle drop
my wrote back Bishop e6 wins the Queen
sneaky stuff here Bishop e6 let's get
the Queen I don't have to take the Queen
she's pinned she's not going anywhere
pawn takes Bishop Queen here's what I'm
gonna do supreme move that then I can
have any time here probably no matter
what unless that was played back to
tournament eight eight eight eight
come on lose already is up there I was
here when that I lost that that last uh
I trying to say well this guy's Mullen
this guy's flyin when I last that I lost
a game that was so painful
last last dream okay they messed up the
move order a little bit so now their
night was inconvenience they're just go
here Bishop f4 mmm Bishop g5 more
aggressive pressure here indirectly to
pieces hitting it Queen e2 let's defend
here might be some tricks rook here pawn
push nights hanging mmm no I have to
defend it directly nice hanging but mmm
go here I could do this night here
Bishop d2 and then after new now let's
defend my knight Queen here hit h6 if
the King goes here he's opposite my
Bishop let's go just right here because
I still want Queen d2 with tempo I maybe
even dark square Bishop exchange let's
grab a tempo King h7 okay they missed
that you take on h7 Queen g5 Queen h4
Knight g5 exchanged our score bishops
Knight g5 this is helping me if their
knight moves there and it's gonna be
trouble so I'm gonna remove the defender
of h7 rook up and over is good too maybe
that's better I'll do this first yeah
this is more direct could take the night
with Czech Queen h7 they should be
mating you know the rook could move
because after
pound takes the queen defense here now
it's gonna be mate queen h8 mate the
rook defends the 7th the 7th and 8th 3
squares the e-file squares back to
tournament 12 john madden he flies
he definitely flies I knew c-4 was
coming I did some prep work mm-hmm
what am i doing I'm moving what was that
move doing dropping material I think
this should be 7 right away would have
been good being sneaky here get rid of
that Knight
get out of there let's take that pawn
stop knight here let's back up back up
I'm gonna dance with my knight get ready
to dance he's going on a journey and the
journey the destination is f4 the bishop
senses it he knows my knight is a pain
he is a giant pain he is a pesky Knight
let's go jump in here Queen takes pawn
is available mm-hmm not anymore not here
huh what's that doing oh this pounds can
be taken I got the file that's a check
pin pieces on Knight takes here hmm you
really shouldn't be able to survive this
around the rook I'm on the night how do
you defend both huh that no you don't
I'm on the knight again
how does it defend the night we're even
on the Clark where's the main that's not
me yes it is me I freaked out about my
pot I'm d4 don't you ever forget about
your pawn on d4 I'm playing this
insurance guy I played this insurance
guy the other day oh man too much fun
the nihms oh the nihms oh it's always a
it's always a fast and furious game with
John man let me tell you mr. X's and O's
is he fast Castle and get on a half-open
files the play
this Bishop's blocking the center pond
let's go back I might want to do that
anyway they chased me later good square
let's attack that guy this is doubled
pawns but I get play on the B file and
maybe some pawn break I'm gonna smash
this open exchange sacrifice right
around the corner they're gonna develop
g3 Bishop g2 here some H Vaughn attack
watch out for that guy
okay he's uh-oh it's weakened these weak
and these these dark squares this is
this is pain it's gonna be painful super
painful Ponte excuse to here take a
couple times here with my rook I could
take that guy take the rook hmm let's
open it up Oh ma'am they didn't mean to
do that I'm pretty sure they didn't mean
to do that
they they resigned back to tournament
it's tough to see when they resigned
it's like it doesn't light up like
there's not a I don't know what I'm
trying to say okay
like weird email Who am I to play a
gambit
that's bullet you could do whatever you
want you could do whatever you want
maybe all right let's develop I have
come that computer impossible computer
possible plays some gambit line against
me this opening let's go here there's no
earlier if my king was still there
there'd be Queen takes pawn with check
let's remove that Knight Queen takes
pawn here Knight here now there should
still be something there is something
that's a serious threat oh that's mate
back to tournament land 24 24 22 2000
okay let's throw in a check here all
right let's develop all right let's
let's castle
let's castle I'm gonna open this up I
shouldn't have captured I just helped
out there pawn structure why would you
ever do that never help out there Pancho
you're like that clean g3 I'm going for
these same little tricks whoo I was
gonna go there anyway I got a pun hittin
the night keeping pressure here
oh why the night they might resign they
reside back determined 20 28 22 my
goodness give me a second to breathe 19
minutes remaining in this tournament
mm-hmm d6 okay with a small pond center
here lining up sneakiness and they put
it into it okay I got space watch out
for the space knight jumping into m5
pawn sack okay now take that give me
this it's launch stuff launch stuff pom
takes it could take this pawn with check
Queen d2 and g5 now they're gonna get
rid of my knight I got the G file though
we're gonna I'm gonna tuck my King in
somewhere maybe know a queenside castle
I don't want to take and open the F file
okay my bishop could be brought to life
I hear I really want to do that um am I
not moving oh my goodness I spent so
much time right there I want to throw my
rook right here oh this is opening up I
don't have a queen trade let's do that
their King is in a box I want to defend
my pawn I'm gonna do this if rook e8
okay my bishop is now free to move oh I
missed that move I have plenty of time
though they spent a lot of time maybe
calculating what I am what am I trying
to say oh man calculating my my probably
unsound
Knight g5 stuff how many time and that's
a pin not going to take that just yet
they resigned back to tournament 32:28 I
have a four point lead we're nearly at
the halfway point Catalans mmm Sicilian
all right it's been a while since I went
fishing mmm this is a good way to uh
stop any fishing pole nonsense this
building of the center all right
more like French defense territory let's
block here watch out for main on f7 I'm
happy to see that actually my bishop was
a dummy anyhow let's develop with tempo
all right well I'm hopeful with trades
and let's do this and recapture here so
he's a he's a weak link but he's an
extra I like him enough no I don't I
don't like him that much let's take this
guy he's passed I'm gonna run with them
let's make sure I could not get back
ring.matted run pun because you're fast
oh that's a wonderful way oh that's a
wonderful way to lose a good past pond a
perfectly good past pond you lost them
oh my goodness are you serious oh they
didn't take my rook I'm getting so loud
oh this is so bad hey God your rook he's
super rapport and you thought your iPod
was important man is your other is your
look important that's the one who's
important let's not have a repetition
hang on to your rope make some trades oh
my goodness was that a free F pawn time
burners watch out for the time burners
okay get rid of my isolated pond back up
no matter what throwing a check no
matter
what time burners watch out for the
sneaky time burners I could take that
pond they're not gonna see it though
check here time burner tactics is the
name of the game sneakiness watch out
for the back ranked mates they are
flying victor king their kings getting a
workout Wow oh my goodness 81 moves in a
1-minute game is a lot 3628 26 26 my
heart skipped a beat when they could
have taken my rook my goodness 14
minutes I would have screamed I would
have screamed if they took my rook I
didn't take my rook though bishop
they're very sophisticated kopeck stuff
is that what we have here where's this
Bishop going tough day now tough day
whoa take that guy he's a freebie isn't
he mm-hmm
Castle let's go here backup do that
not taking take my knight I mean the
tempo against my queen here I guess I
don't want to allow that structural
defect no way double isolated pawns like
that tonight here I'm gonna run home are
you too good for your home Adam Sandler
watch out for Adam Sandler Bishop takes
they could have taken here take here and
then here let's get some trades in um I
was gonna take the Queen if they took
here I just want a piece there let's
take the rook fly out here stuff on this
square Knight here coming soon let's
play here g2 take care
so check here no matter what very
limited with their King now mm-hmm go
here uh-uh
tricky stuff here Bishop here night here
okay night check ooh
I miss that they even had that get out
of there
well what's happens now the 9s move when
I go here let's go here anyway
ah they took that didn't matter they're
down a time back determine 12 12 remain
remains 40 35 30 for 30 mm okay let's go
with d4 here here there Queen c2 Queen
b3 hit amor the week hit'em weather week
b7 oh okay getting a half-open file they
could do that it's super solid it's good
it's definitely good let's get this pond
slinky going throw a question that night
mm-hmm
clever here my dark-squared bishop is a
bad man
he's very very bad I'm not gonna be able
to reinforce that nope I'm not quite
there timing is way off I might have
some sneakiness whoa I feel like I'm
gonna get forked oh my goodness I feel
like I'm gonna get forked any second
this night is so dangerous
oh man now this Knights can enter here
hmm whoa Joe four Forks here I got to
get rid of that night how do we get rid
of him though he's gotta go he's gotta
go you gotta go night he's not going
anywhere
he's gonna go here hmm
oh my goodness ooh am i doing oh no oh
this is so ugly oh man
17 seconds get out of there night you're
no good you're really no good you're
very bad man that's a check I don't know
I want to take what is that oh I could
have taken their queen that was a free
queen time burners and stuff
oh no they're down a chime holding
breath holy breath I can't even complete
my sentences I'm holding my breath
there probably was so dangerous there
nights were so dangerous I should have
lost that one cheating death cheating
death cheating checkmate oh man Oh d3
calm yourself it's only a game it's a
matter with you oh I got the sniffles to
hang out the sniffles I have a very good
pawn structure
who else is saying that right now who
else is saying they haven't a nice pawn
structure and the sniffles mmm it's true
though it's very true push the night and
then f6 who's gonna complain about that
g4 let's run with it at the flying the
Flying V going on right now Flying V
pawn push bishop here might be important
bishop here might be necessary they
gonna do that how they're doing
something like that though Bishop here
here here is the big bad plan on this
pond let's do this though open the
position there down on time uh okay
I'm gonna push through still though h4
and then this uh let's get on the H file
the King could go to f6 to defend but I
could kill the rooks they can't get
active so quick so I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to work somewhere else it's never
really gonna end though right here this
should be this should be the killer King
here I take here back to tournament
forty eight forty three thirty five
sorry about that
there's no time to wipe the now is there
9g 3 by g3 pin that night to take this
pawn next I got a defendant oh my no
they don't have this diagonal up and I
was thinking for a second they didn't
have their seat they had I was thinking
that they had a queen a5 let's take here
here and then push at the end I get that
b7 pawn I maybe even exploit this pin
yeah this should work pile-up on the
pinned piece the Knight has to defend so
that f6 is there but there's Queen stuff
here with check there should be some
stuff and I hear mm-hmm this shouldn't
work let's attack the Queen first I got
this move to I can take this pawn I know
let's gain you temple against the Queen
I have all my pieces working now I'm
gonna chase the Queen off in defense of
the bishop that's one way to do it and
then follow up here and now I'm good
smash through waiting to the very least
tactic of deflection your opponent's
tied down to defending a pin piece
especially
should probably castle but it was that
pun made threats watch out for work here
to here let's just stay out of any
sneakiness back to tournament 52:48 John
Madden is that's the only speed bump he
had is in our game this guy this is the
guy that should have beaten me I think
okay they're not playing d4 and allow
fishing this fishiness h2 sniff that one
oh I'm not going anywhere with him
though another night I hear ya give me
the bishop hair and let's do this
if the knight moves if the knight ever
moves there's some sneaky stuff here on
push I'm fearful of opening up this
stuff here mmm I'll deal with it maybe
like a new pawn push we're still gonna
take here oh my goodness this is
dangerous
oh is this dangerous or what
I can't calculate this just take pieces
you could run a d8 quit being a
scaredy-cat where's the oh they moved I
don't even see that they moved see I
don't have the clock or um I don't have
our sound so it makes it difficult oh
that was terrible what am i doing we
trade makes it difficult to know uh what
am I trying to say this pawn is what I'm
trying to say go here here
know what I'm doing I'm floundering quit
floundering huh
oh no that's a bad way to recapture are
you serious that's with check thankfully
that's with check huh how much time
would you give made already where's the
main get over here get over here he's
running around is that me
that's me no it's not me what you give
made already oh my goodness this is
ridiculous this is very ridiculous oh my
goodness let's try it again they're down
on time oh my goodness how many get how
many moves was that one again that was
ugliness John Madden has a lead 56 56 no
he doesn't have a lead uh we're tied to
have to go in berserk mode I think I do
I just cut my time in half I only have
thirty what they gave me their queen I
only have thirty seconds but I'm gonna
get more points if I win this one open
stuff up
take here no matter what move they're
not moving what are they doing with that
move that's and they got to the pin like
that here here where's the mate
ah I didn't want to do that my teammate
Queen takes here soon where's the main
focus of mate should be right around the
corner very close to me
let's check this is check this check
they got a take maybe I need to get
points here they're gonna take me in one
threat queen g3 that's mate back to
chairman what I get 61 I have a
one-point lead
146 berserk mode again maybe yes or no
I'll try it I'm gonna try it and they're
trying to fishing pole me here night
here I'm gonna do it do this at the
Queen they're trying the fishing pole me
I don't like it not at all okay there's
that move I could now take that night
without any fear
except for my clock so actually I lied
that's check here I'm on the bishop here
back
fifteen seconds oh no oh no oh no no no
no no no no this is ugly nine seconds
huh I can't breathe
why am i pre moving something that isn't
even available okay we're back to even
on time take this pond here secure your
position did I get it in time did I get
the win why his victorious - the
tournament ended though what just
happened there ah we finished just
before I could win that ah man I think
that was down to like the last seconds
that was literally one second before oh
man GG's ah ah man I was uh miss
clicking there towards the end - I think
if I would have been a better Mouse
clicker at the end I would have got that
one ah man talk about talk about being
so close ah that was really really close
and I only noticed that towards the end
the corner of my eye I was seeing it was
like 3 2 1 and my opponent had like
tenths of a second left
there's tenths of a second left two more
seconds not even ah man
alright that was a cool finish nice
alright let's go to uh good games I'll
how many how many participate let's see
John man got first he took the trophy uh
I got second
come on Lou's already third pyruvic this
is the guy he should have got me he
definitely should have had me one or
more times he's super super fast chess
sucks waffles waffle smack Chris one two
three and others how many competed how
many were playing about fifty
these are withdrawals yeah it started
and then quit for whatever the reason
alright
GG's
you
[Music]